this is the first plane to ever break
the sound barrier the Bell X1 on October
14th 1947 the X1 was carried to altitude
under the wing of a b29 with the famed
test pilot Chuck Jagger in the cockpit
dropping from the wing chuck initiated
the x1's Rocket motors and became the
first person to break the speed of sound
designed to be a bullet with wings it
doesn't look much like the supersonic
planes we are familiar with today the
data it gathered helped shape the swept
Delta wings of today's fighter planes
the X1 proved another thing the sound
barrier was not a barrier proving the
feat was possible marked a new era in
aviation an era of wild experimentation
the first of many xpls each designed to
push the limits of our understanding we
will be showing you each and every
xplane that has ever been created in
these shorts so subscribe if you want to
see all of them